[Music]
in age and fertility news submitted by
summer and the West Alanis Morrissette
discusses being pregnant at age 45 oh
man is more sad oh [ __ ] I haven't heard
that name ever
oh my sister loved her that's there's
another it sounds like you loved her
deal no I didn't okay if you sister
loved it it was on the radio like a
[ __ ] though in the night so this
is what she looks like now oh she's
still buddy yeah she looks really good
good for you apparently she was wearing
no makeup in this interview oh [ __ ] her
I know
I know it's really good yeah pregnant
with her third child
this one was sort of like a surprise
pregnancy that's a really big aloe vera
plant you know she used to [ __ ] Joey
from full house and you told us that's
the song the cross I paired it's not bad
the one he was just singing that's right
yeah that you told me you just retold
because I forgot and her hair is
covering her boobs in the tub he has
like a big old she's seen it she's like
she's naming all the cities of the world
or some [ __ ] you don't marry that one no
sounds like you're a fan you want to go
to her live with me no okay
but yeah so she just had this interview
a very long interview if you're curious
you can read it but yeah this took place
back in me and she was just talking
about how different this pregnancy is
from her other two pregnancies and how
she because she ended up experiencing
postpartum depression but she's a very
tough cookie Assoc did she waited a long
time before I was thinking help cuz she
thought it would go away on its own so
for her for her first pregnancy she
waited about a year and a half before
she realized like dang I think I need
help
Oh tell me your house yeah and then the
second pregnancy she waited about four
months before she realized she had
postpartum depression again and then
she's saying with this one she's not
even gonna wait for a minute she's gonna
just immediately go and get hypnotized
it's - just knowing her music though it
seemed like she lived a life of
depression oh yeah she actually sang
about being raped - oh and so she would
like she talks about that in this
interview here - don't she embodies she
embodies sadness and puts it into music
form yeah she's saying she wrote a
jagged little pill when she was 19
still standing behind it because now
they're working on a Broadway musical
around that album and iconic don't and
then I learned through this interview
because the interview person was she's
also Canadian which I didn't know Alanis
was Canadian and she's saying that she
was did you guys ever watch do you know
Robin sparkles sparkles
okay well that's from who how I Met Your
Mother but
she was saying that she was like a pop
star in Canada when she was a child like
a she was a child star but she somehow
managed to transition over to America
and mainstream media in America and
that's how she became the Alanis that we
know but totally different from the
Alanis up they know in Canada so I was
really interesting to read as well but
yeah so she's she was talking about how
now being older she has to be more in
tune with her body because she did
experience eating disorders in her life
and so now she has a healthier
relationship with food but do you guys
know the risks of having a child like
older yeah it's pretty nice isn't it
like a really high chance that your kid
has down syndromes so it's a 1 and 35
chance at the age of 45 that your child
will have a chromosome abnormality I
have normality just the most common
chromosome probably any one of them it
could be different different types and
then so it says one in 85 at the end why
are you clapping do they saw your face
no cuz I pictured like what other extra
chromosomes could it do and I'm like
what if babies come out with a mustache
it's a chromosome thing mustaches yeah
but yeah they're just saying like the
older you are the more risk you have and
if the risk is crazy at 45 specifically
so I could tell you the risk so it's one
in 1480 at the age of 2001 and 940 at
the age of 31 and 353 at the age of 35
well how goes fast one and 85 at the age
of 40 and one in 35 at the age of 45 -
chicks break down quickly the crazy
thing is that the lady still has eggs
until that I can't tell you why so
throughout our entire life or nine tire
life but as soon as we have our first
period you know every single month if
the eggs not being used it gets tossed
out right so these are all the
healthiest eggs the younger you are the
healthier the egg is in order for you to
have a child so the older you get all
the toxic
behind with the shitty eggs I freeze
them yeah when you're younger
that's a stupid design they should have
threw away the [ __ ] bad ones first
you don't keep rotten eggs well back in
the day the bad ones I mean everyone was
getting pregnant at a younger age idea
what [ __ ] at 14 huh
everybody was a pedophile you could get
pregnant as young as eight alright that
was that one girl no no I know as long
as five but was that among village in a
Thailand there were already people
married at 13 14 but not two like all
people they're like sixteen so then the
kids at they end up having it are like
the healthiest pregnant five year old
you said I don't want to talk about it
but in history there's a Peruvian girl
but it's like the Guinness world of
records kind of thing it's not
it's like abnormalities in status yeah
we'd like to proudly announce oh they're
also saying that the older you are the
more likely you are to have a
miscarriage or stillbirth true and
there's also multiple other problems
that can happen the older you are when
you get pregnant so that's why it's
really interesting or like surprising to
hear that Alanis Morissette is primarily
a 1545 money
there's we're so [ __ ] rich they could
have a new body yeah baby
they like eating the best food they're
like getting stem cells and [ __ ] every
other week Jennifer Lopez like 50 or 60
it's just like smooth skin I think she's
in her forties dude she's 50 at least
Oh 49 she's 49 49 is not that far from
people your birthday's delight 24 she's
about to turn 50 dude you know who looks
bomb - is it Jennifer Aniston she's not
a JLo she's good-looking but she's not a
JLo Wow she doesn't look like a
brand-new leather seat no no no not cs50
oh [ __ ] I take it back she looks good
then yeah you're right
she what the [ __ ] I said today you great
competition jess was 40 viewers
oh you gotta you gotta compare all these
chicks I think that's wrong Sandra
Bullock is 54 dude she is my favorite
she has gotten stuff done though she's
the hottest though of all of them no I
guess I mean Madonna that [ __ ] 90
year old she still dances like crazy
what's wrong with her give it her joints
her joints are still [ __ ] working I'm
surprised her joints aren't like they
need [ __ ] wd-40 or she needs to give
I snap back into place by her back a bit
but it's crazy though how people can
still look in yet like if they stay fit
and if they eat right it's like dang Tom
Cruise that looks good too
yeah she looks amazing what is he like
ninety almost sixty isn't it crazy how
Britney Spears looks like a Britney
Spears impersonator now that's a sad
story right there she was like a
Hollywood Highland Britney Spears now
you've been quietly well cuz I don't
know I'm us was he proud of her supposed
to take stance of celebrity maybe now I
don't know what that I don't get what
you did she looks good for forty five
yeah but like what is the thing like
what is having a janessa quoi hour I
think I think it's kind of like whoa
should you be putting that baby into
that is it kind of selfish you know I
got waiting for her child she said this
was an accident it wasn't like it was in
plan well I mean if you're letting
people come in you that's not an
accident right maybe she's going through
pre mom menopause I don't know so she
was just like I can't get pregnant bust
as much as you want and then it happens
I say good for did yeah but I hope it's
helped being great like that's good so
she did mention in the interview that
when she went to the doctor and found
out that the nurse said oh when she told
her her age the nurse was like oh yeah
that's that's super common so like oh
cool moms at forty five is like super
common right now this day and age I
think so yeah so a lot of women are
prolonging their like childbearing stuff
I think it's hard especially if you live
in like a major city and I think like
this city to like LA people are you know
they're getting married late
especially if you want to further your
career and all that stuff and then some
people or a lot of people choose not to
have kids because they have like student
loan debt nor like all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] going on yeah yeah how do you feel
about this whole topic but like you know
you end up having take a older than our
generation yeah yeah you're like an old
lady when you had a tiger say geo being
a [ __ ] keeper how do you feel I don't
really think about it just because I've
had women around me that are older um
safe we have kids cuz your mom had you
guys as a whole data or age too right
yeah I think my mom had my little sister
in her 40s yeah yeah so um so I've seen
that so I'm not too worried about it and
not Mexicans I feel like we got like
good good I know pretty healthy at the
time we're working on and doing all that
stuff
I'm so pretty healthy you know what do
you mean at the time like I put to the
average like that oh hallelujah 33 34 35
yeah to the hundred five anything like
to the average 33 year-old they weren't
training as much as you were or working
out like you were big belly you're still
broken all that stuff yeah yeah I mean
most people are not working out yeah
period like guys and girls I mean so
even if someone walks around the block
once a day that's already more work out
than the average human being that's
crazy
if you think about it the average
American just doesn't move I think
that's the main issue is like not only
the age but the level of activity that
we just don't do anymore
they should make moving more interesting
it's pretty interesting is if you find
the right activity you know what that
that well it's the one the treadmill
where you can like go around the world
and share the Ospreys it what the [ __ ]
[Music]